avec nous ce soir et charges confirme de
qui est le président du groupe st-hubert
on retrouve également steve guimond
corriveau co propriétaire de plusieurs
restaurants qui font partie du groupe
expérience resto dans la région de
rimouski si je me trompe pas dans le bas
saint laurent bonsoir à vous deux
messieurs bonsoir
c'est intéressant de vous avoir les deux
parce qu'on a la perspective d'une
grande chaîne comme saint-hubert puis la
perspective d'une plus petite chaîne ou
plus petit groupe de restaurants j'ai
commencé avec vous monsieur schofield je
présume que vous êtes vous heureux de la
réouverture mais est ce que vous
comprenez pourquoi vous avez été obligé
de fermer depuis un mois
oui on est heureux est ce qu'on comprend
je dois dire est que les semaines un vin
de fermeture on disait que le comité pas
prêt à faire face le derrière
pourquoi on a dû fermer je pense a les
moyens de rester par seulement ouvert
avec encore des limitations mais bon on
nous c'est du passé on est ouvert
aujourd'hui on regarde le futur je
comprends que c'est du passé mais c'est
à 4 fois qu'il ya des fermetures je vous
demandais dans un instant si vous êtes
prêts à une fermeture s'ils savaient ça
devait venir mais monsieur guillemot
corriveau d'abord commencer comment ça
se passe pour vous vous avez quelques
restaurants vous êtes co propriétaire de
quelques restaurants il ya tout un
groupe également comment ça se passe
bien c'est un sport c'est sûr c'est la
première journée de la réouverture on
est bien heureux d'avoir voir une équipe
de travail mais on sera content on se
rend compte que premièrement comme que
le message peut être pas toujours place
la population autant que confirmer que
des gens qui appellent pour pouvoir
réserver encore en salle à manger autant
que leur nous sommes nous voir mais qui
dit qu'avec tout le monde savent que les
restaurants son rival peut avoir un
certain délire est ce que c'est une
réouverture pour vous qu'une forme
d'arrière-goût
alors que
est ce que est ce que les autres
réouverture était plus heureuse est ce
que cette fois-ci vous avez confiance
que vous allez rouvrir est resté ouvert
nombre malheureusement non c'est sûr que
peut-être que les autres et ouverture on
sortait peut-être un peu plus joindre
cinq heures enfin que les accords qui
avaient été menés on a travaillé fort on
investit dans la formation de son
dauphin de notre part pour pour faire
partie de la solution du problème et non
du problème sauf que là on tant qu'on
peut se poser la question pourquoi qu'on
a été fermé il ya un mois on peut se
poser la question du pourquoi qu'on est
ouvert donc pourquoi qu'on refermerait %
seulement pour avoir été permet pourquoi
corps est ouvert pourquoi qu'on veut
faire me répéter cui ya un goût amer il
ya une incertitude ya donc autrement dit
vous ne comprenez plus pourquoi on ferme
que vous ne comprenez pas pourquoi on
rouvre
mamba si c'est vrai et de votre côté
messieurs schofield escales dans votre
esprit vous relancer vos activités les
saint-hubert par tout en sachant très
bien que ça peut encore faire mais
est-ce que vous avez c'est dans l'esprit
certains sont toujours été un esprit on
donne confiance que ça va être on n'est
ce pas la dernière fois je pense va
falloir en aviv être la cage vide je
pense qu'on a toujours démenti on est
des ombres des lieux sécuritaires une
des choses qu'on n'a jamais très bien
compris c'est pourquoi nous on est fermé
vers sissoko masque de qui peuvent
rester au pouvoir je pense que si on
regarde ailleurs dans le monde je pense
on est arrivé à une étape que dit il il
a encore pour plusieurs - faut vivre
avec
tranquillement il faut verser à l'est
les restrictions
est-ce que c'est coûteux pour vous de
rouvrir l'opération réouverture
dans notre compte c'est certain ou vraie
famille a toujours un poisson bon
c'était un mois de fermeture donc moins
on espère du moins personnel ce fossile
on a comme attendu chaque fois pour
embauche de mons et la formation c'est
leur mise en fonction des équipements de
nettoyage en profondeur de l'inoubliable
de vider tout qu'est-ce qui était alors
donc oui à quoi sauver ya autant que
jacou humains à vous aurez pour ces
questions tout allant à l'élite par pour
ces questions là encore plus qu'est-ce
que ils vont fermer encore est ce que
mon travail sécuritaire donc surtout ce
colloque du famas vous avez la même
expérience messieurs guimond corriveau
oui clairement qu'ils week la rendre au
niveau 2 au niveau des employés qui
s'était comme je suis un papa une
indifférence de cette résilience l'avoir
versus ferme et ouvrit est un peu
dangereux pour la passion ça reste un
métier de passion la restauration on
veut que nos cuisines et que nos savoirs
sans reçoit passionnés puis le petit à
petit je pense qu'on met tout le monde
dans un état où il ya un peu de cette
passion lors qu'ils se parlent et je
crois que je pense que si je sais de
quoi qui est très important de
l'industrie la passion qu'on vous fait
vivre une expérience à nos clients
avez-vous de la difficulté à garder vos
employés en ce moment pour cette
réouverture là un peu comme monsieur
vient dire c'est là peut-être un petit
peu moins pire qu'un budget est plus qu
est les gens habitués mais juste et oui
le facteur humain très important la date
parce qu'à force de se réinventer se
réhabituer et s'adapter à ramener les
énergies et des énergies manque de
rentrer sur un cinquième souffle ça
serait le fun ce soit pour de bon est-ce
que vous avez dû augmenter vos salaires
on parlait de salaires qui ont augmenté
de 13 15 20 % est ce que ça a été votre
cas chez vous pas chez nous on a
travaillé fort sur les avantages sociaux
devient en place des programmes de
retraite ont amélioré de certaines
puissances de stock au delà compte aller
qu'en italie de laval ouais et chez
st-hubert
absolument écouter on est plusieurs
franchises et les autres chacun gère le
meilleur qui peuvent dors nous employer
des avantages sociaux des salaires et on
n'a pas le choix d' ajuster pour aide à
marcher mais on va partager aussi
d'écouteurs pour avoir les mains enfin
de clientèle mais oui effectivement on
va prendre soin nos employés puis oui à
des augmentations ou des emplois et un
monsieur schofield à 50 % de capacité ça
vaut la peine d'être ouverts pour vous
est-ce que c'est rentable
pour nous on est quand même chanceux à
cause que les volumes de ventes pour des
commandes remportées livré au demeurant
à rosso de cinq ans ça compense pas la
baisse on met les très grandes salles à
manger comparé à janvier s'est avéré
c'est pour les plus gros moyens sont que
c'est correct pour commencer mon espace
de enlever cette mutation le plus
rapidement possible mais ramener ça à
leurs mailles ou la séparation avec des
mesures en place pour protéger les
clients mais on doit rapidement autres
marques et la capacité de nos salles à
manger et vous monsieur guy môquet
nouveau
c'est la même chose de weedon 50% peut
faire mal dans les périodes plus
achalandé où dans les moments de fin de
semaine et chora mais oui on peut
demeurer avec cette règle mais comme
toutes les règles comme tous les
changements oui à dix coups à la
fermeture à l'ewf et oberthur meilleur
coup au change madrid au changement des
constats parce qu'il faut réhabituer
ford et le star ford et les employés
change et les mesures on se réhabitue
sas à des coûts en énergie le sadique ou
aussi en masse salariale de main des
gens plus sûre sur le marché fixé à ce
niveau alors des fois que ça pète plus
mal de changements constants ouais
merci d'avoir partagé votre expérience
bonne chance pour la suite monsieur
merci merci beaucoup pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici r d
oh